Ben Simmons will head to the line  what is Philadelphia teams  [Applause]  [Music]  I mean I know Durant and urban can shoot  the ball and they put Shooters around  him but make somebody make a jump shot  Candice these are layouts I think you  make somebody make a jump shot but uh  not a good sign for failing with Ben  Simmons stepping up and hitting his  first free throw obviously the crowd  going crazy right now but for confidence  to see that first two free throws go in  that's a lot  foreign  [Music]  they call it bricken for chicken and if  you miss two in the second half nuggets  for everyone so that's why they're so  fired up  Giannis over the Cooper obliged a couple  of days ago and now Ben Simmons will  feed them all here